- The thing what I love about being a chef
is to see the satisfactory
of the guests, the smile.
Dubai is such a vibrant
city, diversity of people,
nationalities that we have,
it's brilliant, it's fantastic.
(upbeat music)
- [Ching] Wherever I am in the world,
food is the focal point
of everything I do.
My name is Ching, and I'm
a TV chef and food writer.
My taste journeys have
taken me all over the world
in search of great
flavors and new recipes.
Finally, it's brought me
to Dubai, and I can't wait
to explore its rich and varied food scene,
one bite at a time.
Reif Othman, internationally
celebrated chef, has worked
in a variety of kitchens, from
fine dining and experiential
cuisine to innovative pop-ups.
Food and family have
always gone hand in hand
and for chef Reif, Dubai has provided
the perfect environment to raise a family
and pursue his culinary adventures.
- Hi, my name is Reif Othman,
and I'm from Singapore.
My family would describe
me as hard working, funny
and little bit crazy.
I would describe myself easy,
free-style, very straight,
on the point.
So, I have two kids, Ayden and
Ally. They are my precious,
they are my life.
- [Ching] My grandmother was
a very important person in my
family's life, and one of
my favorite memories of my
gran was that she'd always
make me and my brothers
packed lunches for school.
I'm really excited to be meeting
a father and chef who does
the same for his children.
- [Reif] So today we are
making a salmon maki roll,
sashimi as well.
- [Ching] Oh wow, they're so lucky.
- Yeah, yeah they're done.
- Great, I'd be happy with that.
- Yeah happy day.
- I mean chef's lunch box!
- It's so multi-faceted, Dubai, isn't it?
Do you feel like that's also
a mirror for who you are,
you're a serious dad,
you're a serious chef.
- [Reif] It's not easy,
but I have to juggle it.
At home you have to be fatherly
figure, but Dubai's been
great, it's giving me
a lot of opportunity.
- [Ching] After meeting
Reif's family, we head to the
waterfront fish market, so that
he could show me the amazing
variety of fresh produce
Dubai's coastline has to offer.
For a chef whose passion is
seafood, I can see why Reif was
excited to bring me here.
- [Reif] Welcome to
waterfront fish market.
They're open 24/7 throughout the year.
Let me show you some salmon fishes.
- They look so fresh!
- Hi, morning.
- [Reif] This is Tuna, Blue
Crab, local fishes, import,
shell fish, you just name it, we have it.
- [Ching] Fantastic.
All your fresh fish, this is
where you get it all from?
- [Reif] Exactly, plenty of choice, yeah,
plenty of choice, yes.
Once I pick some fish that I want.
- [Ching] OK.
- Maybe I bring it to my
local fish restaurant.
Are you hungry?
- I'm always hungry.
- Let's do it.
- (laughs) Okay.
Our next stop, Bu Qtair,
where one has to try the
specialty fried fish.
- They're famous for their fried fish.
- OK.
- And so, prawns?
- Yeah, I'm really excited.
Oh wow, look at that!
- Here we have the Sheri
Fish, they marinated it
with masala curry.
- And it's packed here, it's lunch time.
- It's always packed, even
dinner, there's a queue.
- [Ching] So how do we start?
- You use your hands.
- OK, really get the mix of spices.
- Yes, a nice balance.
- It's got the sweetness
of the flesh of the fish.
So simple, and I love
it, simplicity is key.
But I want to try your food.
- Yeah, why not, let's go, let's
go to my restaurant and you
see my take on doing my fish, all right?
(upbeat music)
- Here we have Sea Bass Ceviche Tartare.
- Uh-huh, lovely.
- [Reif] And we have a (mumbles)
- All in one go, that was really good,
the fish is delicious!
- Yeah, we get freshly three times a week
from Japan (mumbles).
So here we have the Jet
and Bruce Lee Wagyu beef,
and the rice is from Kyoto.
- [Ching] Okay.
- Only the emperor is eating this rice.
- That is delicious, that
is comfort in a bowl,
unbelievably delicious!
- Thank you, thank you. (laughs)
Dubai is growing now,
with a lot of restaurants
opening, a lot of big chefs
coming in, it's all about
to achieve and to give
the best experience to our
customers, to our diners, you know.
We do have some home-grown
restaurants, made by
home-grown talents as well.
(upbeat music)
- [Ching] I didn't realize
that you could have such a vast
array of choice and
delicious food in Dubai.
From street food to fine dining
and everything in between.
My time in Dubai has been
multi-faceted, vibrant,
full of flavor, full of
culture, and I can't wait
to come back.